bonjour c'est xavier dolan pour brut
[Musique]
c'était le gamin du chu où je me
reconnais beaucoup dans cette dans cette
admiration éperdue en fait qui km et pas
juste me reconnaître les écrits
[Musique]
dir herr cet enfant reste toi même soir
toujours toi même je pense que l'enfant
serait serait heureux l'enfant serait
épanouie il en france l'enfant serait
serait satisfait de voir ce qu'on lui et
moi ce qu'ensemble on a en effet je
pense qu'il voudrait être nulle part
ailleurs peut-être qu'il voudrait être
plus à hollywood ou avec des gens plus
connus mais ça c'est la superficialité
un peu de temps quand on est jeune on a
peut-être connu plus que de faire des
vraies choses qui ont la valeur tout
début de ma vingtaine j'ai voulu être un
peu quelqu'un d'autre un autre artiste
un autre humain à un autre puis
rapidement je je suis revenu à l'assaut
survenu vers qui je suis vraiment puis
j'ai arrêté la voir part d'affirmer
qu'ils qui j'étais mes films ont
toujours été je pense très personnelle
puis assez représentatif malgré tout 2
qui j'étais à l'époque mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu un moment de ma vie où je
sais pas j'ai joué un peu à être un
autre j'ai de la difficulté à comprendre
certains passages de mon existence pour
sécher des films pour en parler un peu
pour essayer de faire la lumière sur sur
des épisodes qui toujours je l'espère
que je le crois peut-être naïvement vont
intéresser d'autres personnes que moi il
n'y a pas de recette et pas de formules
en fait pour pour se comprendre pour
grandir la chose que j'ai comprise avec
le temps c'est qu'être soi même puis se
battre pour qu'il en est c'est là la
seule façon en fait de survivre à la
conformité à la lah à la au manque
d'aspérités de la société le manque
d'aspérités le manque de différence
c'est la fin de toutes les idées toutes
les idées puis tous les progrès à
l'origine de toutes les équipes de tout
des progrès il ya toujours une
différence il ya toujours une notion
différente et toujours une divergence
d'opinion et puis c'est dommage de dire
à quelqu'un qui ne se comprend pas ou
qui n'est pas compris qu'il doit être ou
devenir comme les autres parce que c'est
vraiment là qu'on est en train d'
d'aseptiser la qualité puis la
différence puis le
la possibilité je pense d'un changement